auf der ganzen welt gibt es kein
fertiges atommüllendlager etwa 30 länder
dieser welt betreiben rund 440
atomreaktoren
doch das fatale daran keines dieser
länder verfügt über ein fertiges
endlager das im besten fall auch noch
eine million jahre lang sicher sein soll
und tropisch sagen fachleute
wohin also mit dem ganzen atommüll ist
die sogenannte transmutation vielleicht
eine realistische lösung kriegs um
science-fiction hier gibt es drei mal
pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann und nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen klicks und gibt es jetzt
übrigens auch als podcast für unterwegs
auf die ohren die links spotify und
apple podcasts sind unten in der video
beschreibung ja schön und gut wenn
deutschland in zwei jahren 2022 sein
letztes atomkraftwerk vom netz nehmen
will
doch es gibt einen großen haken die rede
ist von etwa 10.000 500 tonnen
radioaktiven abfalls und wohin der
kommen soll ja das weiß noch niemand so
richtig wäre es möglicherweise eine
option in tief im meer zu versenken ihn
zu recyceln oder ihn ganz einfach ins
weltall zu schießen noch ist man auf der
suche nach einem ort für ein endlager wo
der ganze atommüll dann isoliert und
dauerhaft gelagert werden kann
denn klar ist er ist sowohl für uns
menschen als auch für die umwelt
hochriskant mit diesem problem steht
deutschland allerdings nicht alleine da
weltweit existiert achtung noch kein
einziges fertiges endlager finnland hat
zumindest schon mal mit dem bau
angefangen und zwar am standort eines
der finnischen atomkraftwerke in
olkiluoto frankreich hat immerhin einen
möglichen standort im visier und die
schweiz analysiert das gestein an zwei
möglichen standorten um auf der suche
nach einem endlager endlich einmal einen
großen schritt nach vorne zu kommen
andere länder dagegen planen und bauen
sogar weitere neue atomkraftwerke dabei
liegen die usa mit 99 atomkraftwerken an
der absoluten spitze danach kommen
frankreich mit 58 und japan mit 43
atomkraftwerken china plant gerade ganze
20 neue atomkraftwerke die zusätzlich zu
den 37 laufenden anlagen in betrieb
genommen werden sollen die anzahl der
weltweiten kraftwerke ist also
erschreckend hoch und das obwohl es
immer noch kein sicheres endlager für
den hochradioaktiven müll
diese anlagen gibt und das seit 65
jahren 65 jahre nach dem start des
ersten kommerziellen atomkraftwerkes
1955 in großbritannien das ist schon
verrückt da hat man eine technik
gestartet die zum einen nicht
zuverlässig funktioniert wie unzählige
atomunfälle zeigen fukushima und
tschernobyl sind der lebende richtig
spitze des eisbergs und zudem weiß man
einfach nicht wohin mit dem tödlichen
müll in deutschland wären noch in den
kommenden elf jahren bis 2031 nach einem
geeigneten standort ausschau halten der
stark strahlende abfall aus mehr als 20
kernkraftwerken soll dann tief in der
erde vergraben werden und zwar womöglich
in einem eigens dafür errichteten
bergwerk für eine million jahre lang
sollen dort vor allem die abgebrannten
brennelemente aus den reaktoren fest und
sicher eingeschlossen werden
doch klar ist schon jetzt niemand will
den atommüll freiwillig in seiner nähe
haben
das hat auch das beispiel gorleben
gezeigt die hat die westdeutsche
bundesregierung in den 70er jahren schon
einmal einen vermeintlichen standort
gefunden der als endlager geeignet
schien eine dicht besiedelte region und
ein neues bergwerk dass arbeitsplätze
versprach doch die öffentlichkeit wurde
nicht wirklich über die pläne informiert
und der ganze gorleben plan machte die
deutschen kernenergie gegner erst so
richtig stark nach vielen protesten und
der atomkatastrophe in fukushima von
neun jahren 2011 wurde wo leben dann als
möglicher standort aufgegeben doch die
frage nach einem passenden ort ist
dringender als je zuvor welche
bodenbeschaffenheit ist dafür am besten
geeignet granit wie im süden und
südosten deutschlands oder eher
salzstöcke wie im norden möglicherweise
kommt aber auch ton in betracht und der
findet sich vor allem in der mitte
deutschlands und im norden des landes
seit frühling des vergangenen jahres
2019 informiert das bundesamt für
entsorgungssicherheit bfg darüber wie
die endlagersuche in deutschland abläuft
wie man sich an den prozessen beteiligen
kann und auch welche regionen überhaupt
in frage kommen doch ist es überhaupt
möglich ein endlager zu schaffen dass
tatsächlich für eine million jahre lang
sicher ist fest steht das ist ein
wahnsinnig langer zeitraum wenn man sich
überlegt dass es den modernen menschen
erst seit 300.000 jahren gibt erst seit
wenigen jahr 1000 gibt es hochkulturen
doch einige spaltprodukte des atommülls
haben sehr sehr lange halbwertszeit ein
beispiel plutonium 239 dass nach einer
kernspaltung im reaktor in den
abgebrannten brennstäben bleibt das ist
erst nach 24 jahren zur hälfte in
stabile isotope zerfallen die nicht mehr
weiter strahlen
doch in kernkraftwerken entstehen noch
weitere isotope und die sind teilweise
sogar noch länger aktiv in deutschland
gibt es das sogenannte
standortauswahlgesetz demnach ist ein
zeitraum von einer million jahre
vorgeschrieben für die lagerung viele
fachleute halten es jedenfalls für
unrealistisch ein lager zu schaffen das
wirklich eine million jahre lang sicher
ist denn es müsste nicht nur vor
erdbeben und wasser geschützt werden
sondern auch vor den menschen die in der
zukunft leben
somit müssten wir also die nächsten
30.000 generationen vor unserem atommüll
war
doch es gibt bislang kein
kommunikationsmittel dass ich so lange
hält sogar buchstaben auf stein also
eingeritzte zeichen die könnte man nach
einigen jahrtausenden wohl nicht mehr
entziffern könnten religionen das wissen
über den atommüll weitergeben oder gar
genmanipulierte lebewesen die vor
radioaktivität waren in dem sie leuchten
zumindest für die etwa 300.000
kubikmeter schwach- und
mittelradioaktive abfälle gibt es ein
erstes endlager in deutschland und zwar
das stillgelegten eisenerz bergwerk in
salzgitter hier also kommen einfache
putzlappen und der bauschutt der
abgebauten kernkraftwerke unter doch das
reicht noch lange nicht und die zeit
drängt denn die gegebenheiten auf der
erde ändern sich durch den klimawandel
sogar noch schneller als gewöhnlich und
das sorgt bereits jetzt für probleme so
droht beispielsweise eine
umweltkatastrophe im pazifik da hier ein
atommülllager bröckelt und darunter ist
auch eine der giftigsten substanzen der
welt geben plutonium 239 schon vor
jahrzehnten wurde hier in der südsee
hoch radioaktives material unter einem
betondeckel vergraben insgesamt handelt
es sich um 85.000 kubikmeter
zu klaren abfalls das entspricht etwa
dem fassungsvermögen von achtung 35
olympischen schwimmbecken
bei dem atommüll handelt es sich um
überbleibsel von amerikanischen
atombombentest gesichert ist das ganze
mit einem betondeckel der etwa 50
zentimeter dick ist dieser soll
verhindern dass die umwelt mit den
strahlenden stoffen aus den atomtests
von damals kontaminiert wird doch das
ganze wurde er behelfsmäßig installiert
denn ursprünglich war das projekt nur
als vorübergehende lösung für das
atommüllproblem angedacht so wurde
beispielsweise der untergrund nicht
versiegelt der müll liegt also direkt
auf dem insel boden doch 2013 gab es
erste hinweise auf risse in der
betondecke diese tauchten in einem
bericht des us energieministeriums auf
auch laut einer dokumentation des
australischen senders abc
besteht die gefahr dass der decke des
atoms undicht geworden ist oder es
zeitnah noch werden könnte
der umweltschützer elsen vielen warnt
vor allem zitat verheerenden ereignis
wir sprechen dabei nicht nur über die
marshall-inseln sondern den gesamten
pazifik fest steht jedenfalls nicht nur
ein starker tropensturm in der region
stellt ein enormes risiko dar
auch der steigende meeresspiegel als
folge des klimawandels wird zur
drohenden gefahr wenn auch dadurch
könnte die beton koppel brüchig werden
und die usa
sie lehnen jede verantwortung ab obwohl
sie das dort abgelagert haben sie werden
jetzt nicht mehr zuständig doch wäre es
nicht sowieso eine gute idee den
radioaktiven abfall tief im meer zu
versenken die meere sind durch den
menschen ja sowieso schon enorm
verstrahlt ab den 70er jahren nämlich
gab es weltweit mehr als 250
nuklearwaffen tests auf hoher see und
nicht nur das bis anfang der 90er jahre
wurde das meer außerdem als riesige
müllkippe für große mengen atommüll
genutzt
nach angaben der internationalen
atomenergie organisation iaea sind von
1946 bis 1993 weltweit mehr als 200.000
tonnen zum teil hoch radioaktiven
abfalls in den meeren gelandet das
japanische umweltministerium überlegt
daran anzuknüpfen es geht um hunderte
weiße und blaue tanks die alle voll mit
radioaktivem wasser sind insgesamt
handelt es sich wohl um mehr als eine
million tonnen kontaminiertes wasser aus
kühlleitung von fukushima der atomunfall
in japan hinterlässt also einen
rattenschwanz an problemen so hat jetzt
die betreiberfirma tepco verkündet dass
der platz zur aufbewahrung für das
belastete wasser knapp werde
bis zu 150 tonnen seien es pro tag die
abzupumpen sein
damit dieses wasser nicht in die natur
gelangt doch spätestens 2022 ist trotz
tepco kein platz mehr für weitere tanks
schon jetzt ist dort eine riesige fläche
mit riesigen tanks bedeckt dazu der
ehemalige umweltminister yoshiaki harada
im vergangenen herbst 2009 10 die
einzige möglichkeit ist es ins meer zu
entleeren und zu verdünnen
die betreiberfirma tepco will das wasser
filtern und so von radionukliden
befreien
doch das ist nur zum teil möglich das
wasser wird durch riesige röhren
geleitet die mit kiesel artigen material
befüllt sind hierbei handelt sich um
sogenannte ionentauscher tatsächlich
werden durch diesen prozess zumindest
die cäsium und strontium isotope
entfernt doch tepco musste bereits vor
zwei jahren 2018 zu geben das serien
austausch 829 nur unzureichend heraus
filtern dabei strahlt gerade dieses
isotop sehr lange denn es hat eine
halbwertszeit von 15 millionen jahren
das heißt dass sich seine ursprünglich
vorhandene menge alle 15 millionen jahre
halbiert dazu kommt tritium verbleibt im
wasser dabei handelt es sich um ein
schweres isotop vom wasserstoff mit
fatalen folgen denn das tritium
verbindet sich mit sauerstoff zu einem
wassermolekül dass strahlung abgibt um
somit selbst radioaktiv ist das große
problem dabei ist dass es sich
physikalisch gesehen genauso wie
normales wasser verhält das tritium
wasser lässt sich also nur sehr schwer
entfernen fachleute sind sich jedenfalls
einig das ist keine option ist
radioaktiven müll im meer zu versenken
wenn er müll verteilt sich dort nicht
gleichmäßig außerdem besteht selbst bei
geringer radioaktivität das risiko dass
es sich in der nahrungskette anreichert
so dass bestimmte tiere dann quasi als
endlager dienen und besonders stark
strahlen und darüber wird es
letztendlich dann wieder bei uns
menschen in gesundheitsschädlichen dosen
landen wäre es nicht eine option den
ganzen atommüll ins weltall zu schießen
ein großes problem stellen die kosten da
denn man braucht wahnsinnig
die raketen mit atommüll beladen um sie
ins all zu schießen zudem wissen wir
alle dass sie der raketenstart ein
risiko ist und das will man
verständlicherweise nicht eingehen denn
wenn der start einer rakete mit atommüll
an bord des klicken würde wären die
folgen für das leben auf der ganzen erde
verheerend das fazit also lautet dass es
nicht wirklich alternativen zu einem
endlager
auf der erde gibt doch möglicherweise
könnten uns technologien dabei helfen
atommüll zu recyceln und zu entschärfen
die rede ist von der sogenannten
transmutation das bedeutet so viel wie
umwandlungen so könnte der atommüll an
halbwertszeit verlieren was kommt vor
allem für den hoch radioaktiven abfall
in frage der zwar nur rund zehn prozent
des gesamten atommülls aus macht aber
dabei achtung 99 prozent der
radioaktivität erzeugt bei der
transmutation sind solch ein
hochradioaktiver langlebiger atome mit
sehr energiereichen schnellen neutronen
beschossen gespalten und in isotope mit
deutlich kürzerer lebensdauer verwandelt
so kann man zumindest das grundprinzip
der transmutation beschreiben danach
strahlt der atommüll zwar noch aber
deutlich weniger
die halbwertszeit lässt sich somit auf
500 bis 1000 jahre reduzieren deutlich
deutlich weniger also als die
angedachten eine million jahre zwei
anwendungen werden derzeit für die
praxis erforscht doch deutschland will
diese technologie nicht nutzen so heißt
es in einem abschlussbericht der
kommission lagerung hochradioaktiver
abfall stoffe von der transmutation also
der umwandlung langlebiger radionuklide
in weniger langlebige nuklide wird
erwartet das entsorgungsproblem
zumindest vereinfachen zu können doch
die technologie sei zu teuer und zudem
noch nicht weit genug entwickelt ohne
frage die technologie steckt in der
praxis noch in den kinderschuhen und
große transformation anlagen gibt es
noch nicht im labor
dagegen konnten die entscheidenden
schritte durchgeführt werden viele
fragen sind noch offen und zwar unter
anderem zur brennstoff herstellung und
zur neutronen erzeugung fachleute
schätzen dass eine erste anlage erst in
20 jahren ihren betrieb aufnehmen könnte
in japan und in belgien entstehen
derzeit zwei demonstrationsanlagen doch
dabei handelt es sich nicht um
waschechte transmutation anlagen sondern
um testanlagen für ein beschleuniger
betriebenes system und das
die voraussetzung um überhaupt eine
transmutation anlage zu bauen
dennoch macht es sinn die forschung in
diesem bereich auszubauen
deshalb würde selbst mit transmutation
ein endlager für hoch radioaktive
abfälle notwendig sein da kommen wir
also nicht drum herum doch durch eine
weiterentwicklung der bislang
erforschten transformationsprozesse
müssen wir nicht weiter darauf hoffen
ein bislang nicht existentes endlager zu
finden indem unsere nuklearen abfall
eine million jahre lange sicher verwahrt
werden kann stattdessen könnte ein teil
des atommülls transportiert werden mit
einer technologie die zwar geld kostet
aber in naher zukunft möglicherweise
verfügbar sein könnte umweltkatastrophe
im pazifik in diesem video hier
unbedingt anklicken erfahrt ihr mehr
über den undichten atommüll bunker
clixoom nature dafür anklicken anschauen
und auf jeden fall abonnieren wir
brauchen noch ein paar abos und außerdem
erfahrt ihr dort mehr über natur und
umwelt also eigentlich ein muss bis dann
bleibt dran